It turns out that this answer is also log base b of 5. Great work if you got
this right. Again, I think it's best to think about splitting this up into two
logarithms. Log base b of 5 and log base b of 5. We're adding three logarithms
together right here. So, we can really just multiply these arguments together.
So, we'll have log base b of 3 times 5 times 5. That's how we can combine these
three logarithms through addition. And then we'll have minus log base b of 15
on the end. And finally to subtract two logarithms with the same base, we'll
divide the second one into the first one. So we'll have log base b of three
times five times five divided by 15. We have the factors of 15, which reduced
to one, which leaves us with log base b of five. Now, there was one other way
we could have solved this problem and it involves using the power rule. Let's
see what that would look like. We could've started by moving this 2, backup as
an exponent for the 5. So 2 times log base be a 5 would equal log based b a 5
squared. Now we can apply the same rules for adding logger items with the same
base. And subtracting logarithms with the same base. When we add these 2
logarithms together, we'll have log base b of 3 times 5 squared. We simply
multiply these two numbers together. And finally here, we'll divide this number
into this number. So to combine these logarithms when subtracting, we'll have
the log base b of 3 times 5 squared divided by 15. Notice that 5 squared is the
same thing as 5 times 5. So we're really back to what we ended with last time.
Our factor of 15 simplifies to 1 so we're left with log base b of 5.